[Music]
Allah sent his Messenger to call people
to Eternal success and that is why
Muslims in Norway are now establishing a
Masid and da Center to enhance the
Norwegian da but they cannot do this
alone we need to support them if you
donate to the scores you will inshallah
reap the rewards of thousands of Muslims
coming back to Islam so click the link
and donate now and share the video for
extra reward asalam alikum my dear
brothers and sisters in Islam welcome to
another episode of our Ramadan Series
where we dive deep into the false claims
of islamophobes expose misinformation
with solid facts and Truth in today's
episode we respond to a man who claims
to have been a devout Muslim for 16
years only to convert to Christianity
what prompted such a dramatic change in
his life certain recurring issues he
says led him to question the faith he
had preached and defended for over a
decade and a half in this video he uses
Quran chapter 4 verse 24 which states
also forbidden a married woman accept
female captives in your possession to
explain why he not only left Islam but
also relentlessly attacks what he claims
to be an evil ideology let's hear what
he has to say both the Quran and
Muhammad teach that it's permissible
Halal to
capture and rape female War captives
even if these women are married and
their non-muslim husbands are still
alive so let's investigate the Islamic
sources to see what they say the Quran
in chapter 4: 22 and 23 informs Muslim
men about the categories of women which
they are forbidden to marry but in Ayah
number 24 we
read also forbidden are women already
married except those whom your right
hands possess mamed what is the wisdom
Behind These verses would you like to
elaborate on
that yeah sure I mean first and foremost
what he's actually claimed about those
verses are flatly false I mean they're
baseless lies flat-footed assumptions
because the truth of the matter is that
the Quran first and foremost has an
emancipatory discourse the like of which
the Bible does not have for example in
it
mentions that what is the good way the
good way is freeing slaves so if someone
is going to be fair about the quranic
discourse as a whole they would first
have to start by saying there is an
emancipatory discourse and of course
there are many ways in which freeing a
slave is an obligation uh you free a
slave for example if you take an oath
you free a slave for example if you do
something called vhar and the all these
things are mentioned the Quran right so
you have these all Pathways of freeing
slaves in Islam which indicates that
it's a good thing and obviously the
Quran says itself it's a good thing that
freeing slaves is a good thing someone
would argue that why is there not an
Abol abolition of the slaves why is it
like that because this is what people
don't understand we're living in the
21st century and when they try and
abolish things I mean they've tried to
abolish things only just recently in for
example the abolition in America it
doesn't work like that I mean sometimes
it falls apart something which is deeply
entrenched into the economic fabric of a
society needs to be graded out of the
society in a in a kind of incremental
gradualist manner so the first thing one
could argue is yes that freeing slaves
is something that Islam and the Quran
wants us to do in fact some of theis
great AIS of Islam people like shab and
others have actually mentioned this
quite explicitly so that's the first
thing that needs to be mentioned just
mentioned here which I think is
extremely important is that there's no
doubt that Islam the Quran in particular
has an emancipatory discourse going to
the verses in question it's not just
verse 24 but it's many other vers in the
Quran this the the phrase right hand
possess is mentioned to be fair the
phrase slave is not mentioned and in
fact the prophet Sall wasallam in a
Hadith explicitly said you know do not
call
somebody you know your master or your
slave instead call him young man this
and that so this kind of language is not
encouraging in Islam and it should be
noted as well that you of course the
word slave in the English language and
in particular in Western culture is Frau
with racist connotations because of the
slave uh the transatlantic slave trade
which was predicated on a racial
Prejudice the like of which we have not
witnessed in the Islamic discourse not
to say we haven't witnessed it in the
Muslim world that's a different question
of course there is racism in the Muslim
world has always been racism in the
Muslim world and tribalism something the
prophet actually tried to combat at his
time himself but we're talking about the
Islamic discourse and we we have the
famous Hadith the prophet saying so
you're saying that you should not call
someone whom your right hand possess
which is the term that the Quran uses
yes you should not call them your slave
right absolutely and while we have the
term slave but it is used in reference
to Allah we are the slaves of Allah sure
yeah so the thing is I mean if you think
about what's actually happening here
what's actually happening is that you
have people that are taking over other
other cities or countries or places and
then you have a surplus of women and
children who because their husbands have
died in war Etc now they need to be
reintegrated into society and when
they're being reintegrated in society
now they become what is referred to as
right-and possess now right hand possess
is something that is not specific to the
Islamic you know sphere or the Islamic
communities is something which every
essentially every Empire was doing at
the time so Islam came to regulate this
process and through the regulation for
example the Z period there is a period
of you can call it transition this um
where the woman is not just you know
having intercourse with a man as soon as
he conquers the area no there is a
transitional period and then the the
allegation of rape or you can rape I
find this quite incredulous in fact and
and the reason why I find this
incredulous and actually
implausible as per the Islamic discourse
is simply because Islam's one of Islam's
major uh principles is a
that harm is to be averted the prophet
said it
himself there is no harming yourself or
reciprocating harm yes so I don't
understand rape is one of the most
manifest expressions of harming somebody
definitely you cannot say that Islam
allows something which its principles
disallow in essence yeah raping a woman
against her will and so on and so forth
this is something that you cannot
imagine that Islam allows you know so
whether it's in a a marital setting or
whether it's in um this I'll give you
I'll give you a two or three examples of
this which will kill the the completely
it will kill it bring it on yeah number
one the Hadith which is actually a
controversial Hadith okay of the Prophet
Muhammad wasam where basically he said
that um if your if your wife doesn't
have intercourse with you at night then
the angels will curse her okay that
Hadith indicates no um there is no uh uh
foring there there is no Consequence the
man immediate Consequence the man should
enact because there's another re way of
the Hadith that says that he'll be
tossing and turning all night which
means he's sexually frustrated now so in
other words if it was the case that he
was meant to be enacting his uh the
sexual thing then he wouldn't be tossing
and turning number one number two which
is even more powerful people don't know
this one and I'll tell you it today
right now that this is mentioned bukari
the had a wife no one knows her name
even her name was been to Joan she's not
mentioned in the books of many books and
stuff like that the viewers will say
what they say yes you know this new
information this is why they should
invest in an Islam net so they can get
this crucial golden nuggets that they
would not get B to Joan B to Joan
married the prophet
Muhammad first night she
said so she I seek refuge in Allah from
you now what does that mean why did she
say it it's all vague it's ambiguous
now this was at the point where the
consumation was meant to happen the
prophet Muhammad how did he react to
this
Behavior he told her to go back to her
family which is a divorce yes the
prophet divorced this woman before he
even had intercourse with her now what
does this indicate now if this if rape
was allowed yes it doesn't why would he
tell her to go back why would he tell
her to go back he should have just
forced himself upon her and so on and so
forth that did not happen in fact this
kills two in one kills one which is that
rape is allowed in Islam which is false
yes anyone who says this and that and
these arguments are weak anyone who says
raping and sexually assaulting a woman
crying and this and that how you think
Islam allows it does not allow I can
tell you does not allow this yeah you
have a misunderstanding of the
principles of Islam if you think that
you can force yourself upon a woman
whether she is your wife or whether she
is a slave or whether you have a
misunderstanding and you you're actually
a weak and insecure man if you're a
Muslim who believes this because that's
how may yeah because why would you need
to force a woman to be with you the
prophet sallam mallah you're still here
just make sure that you donate by
clicking the link below cuz the rewards
are
unimaginable the way he dealt with the
matter okay was that as soon as he
sensed hesitation he ended termination
he ended everything you go we so subh
this is mentioned bukari so that's the
second thing we mentioned yes the third
thing I mentioned now so we mentioned
the emancipated discourse number one
which is Undisputed it's Undisputed
incontrovertible indubitable something
mentioned in the Quran and yes number
two we mentioned the Hadith that I've
just mentioned right now yeah number
three we explained the transitional
period number four we explained the
incremental aspect of Islam and how it
number five now this person he says is
Christian and this is where it's the
golden bullet this is where it's knock
out because if if your problem is that a
religion endorses sexual intercourse
rape uh sexual assault um intercourse
with minors even because that's another
sh but we'll bring it all in one yes
then I would like him to read Numbers
Chapter number 31 verse number 18 and in
fact forget about just reading that cuz
someone will say that's your
interpretation I'm going to read out to
you right now the professional opinion
of Shane Cohen who is the profess of
Hebrew literature and philosophy in the
department of near Eastern language and
civilization for Harvard University
itself he explains that when the Bible
mentions in chapter number 31 verse
number 18 but all of those female
children this is what it's mentioned
this is the Jubilee Bible 2000 but all
the female children words in Hebrew is T
mhm that have not known a man by lying
with him keep alive for your yourself
Shane kohen who is one of the top
Scholars and you can tell he's from a
Jewish background
himself he says for yourself is clear
that Moses's soldiers could use females
sexually use them sexually he continues
Moses enjoins upon the returning
Warriors to kill their uh midianite
female captives who have Lain with a man
but spare for yourself every young woman
who has not had carnal relations with a
man we may be sure he's saying that for
yourself he's saying we may be sure
means that the Warriors may use their
virgin captive sexually this is what
he's
saying and this is mentioned Shane kohen
and his in his book the book is called
the beginnings of jewishness boundaries
varieties uncertainties University of
California press Berkeley Los Angeles
London and it is page number 255 256
he's not the only person who says this
you have rabbis going all the way back
who say the same thing your Bible says
this now someone will say well the Bible
was the Old Law well I say well you
believe in the Trinity which means that
the Jesus is the author of the Old
Testament he is the author he is
commanding you to rape according to you
do not tell me you're leaving a religion
which does not have a the word rape is
not mentioned anywhere in the Quran
sunah I Dare Challenge to my challenge
find the word rape anywhere let alone an
instruction to do such a thing y huh
that's number one number two as I
mentioned emancipatory discourse and
this and that and the other the argument
I made number three find me an
equivalent verse of Numbers 3118 in the
b in the Quran doesn't
exist so you're you're moving from a
religion that explicitly does not
endorse such a thing to a religion which
explicitly endorses such a thing and
which your God commanded to that thing
how dare you every accusation is a
confession you don't know your own text
and if you're ingenuous and if you are
authentic then you will really forget
about becoming Muslim we don't need you
to become Muslim leave Islam do this do
what you want we don't
care as the Quran says do what you
want whoever wants to come believe and
whoever wants to can
disbelieve I have my religion you have
yours no problem all that is
fine but now according to your
principles your moral standards you must
leave Christianity that's true you must
if you're a Jew you must leave Judaism I
want you to announce your apost your
apostasy from Christianity if you don't
then you're disingenuous you're lying
Hypocrites you're and or you're lying
about the whole thing yeah so it's it's
up to you now you you have to enure the
contradictions you must enure the
contradictions it's up to you but the
the evidences have been provided the
references are there and I can show you
a plethora Myriad evidences to this
effect and I think that completely
smashes the sh I don't know what you
think yeah it's destroyed it's
absolutely destroyed yes I don't think
there's anything left to say after that
except that brothers and sisters if you
want us to keep producing this kind of
quality material making it available for
the masses challenging these false false
accusations and refuting these
individuals who are spreading lies
against our faith then you need to be
part of this project you need to be part
of the Islam net dawa movement yes where
we are challenging these things with
with your donations brothers and sisters
you can share in the immense rewards of
producing these high level Productions
you can share in the immense reward of
establishing this Masid that we are in
right now producing this consider
ourselves and I want them to imagine
this imagery that we are in a bunker and
we are firing the most potent and
important
intellectualized missiles to the enemies
of Islam these intellectual missiles are
landing on target you're not going to
get a a a missile that lands more On
Target than with Islam net mamad hijab
connection bro this the Islam net
movement there's no tell me of a place
where the intellectual missiles of Islam
hit heart into the into the heart land
of the anti-muslim unit More Than This
there is not one there is not one in the
world so if you want to fund something
and you want to protect your children
and your grandchildren press the button
what are you waiting for what do you
want what do you want to see next who do
we have to defeat next what kind of
intellectual proof do you want to see
next Subhan Allah Subhan
Allah so brothers and sisters it's the
month of Ramadan this is the month of
giving charity this is the month that
the prophet sallallah wasallam was the
most generous of all times if you do not
take a part in this in this production
in this studio in this Masjid in all of
the great work that we doing to elevate
the religion of Allah then I don't know
what you will be spending your money on
this is the best insh T of the best of
the best avenues that you can put your s
this Ramadan so for that sake I ask you
click the link it will only take a few
seconds few seconds yeah it'll take you
as much as you do scrolling and this and
that let's be honest how long you spend
in a toilet how much you wash your hands
bro this imagine you you can be saving
someone's IM yeah there's a high chance
that by pressing the link and do
pressing someone bringing someone to
Islam why not let's be honest we're not
going to be as charitable in other parts
of the Year Ramadan is the time where
Allah he does of the rewards he
multiplies it Sevenfold 10 fold 100 fold
millionfold we don't know how Allah does
it but it will be amazing and so imagine
doing it now it's like the best return
of investment you might die tomorrow
when are you going to do it just do it
yeah and even the content that we went
through in this video it's so profound
everyone have have had this sh once in
in their lifetime they've thought about
it okay Islam teaches about slavery
raping women we've heard this we've
heard that but we don't have a clear
answer the answer has been clarified
today so brothers and sisters make the
donation click the link and we will see
you in the next episode
[Music]